(upbeat music)
- [Whispered Voices] Dead Kevin.
- I like the first one.
The second one was a little...
I think Dennis Quaid's
making a comeback, man.
- Nah, the second
one was good, man.
- He still has a really
young face, you know?
- Oh, for sure.
- Oh, wait!
You guys have your keys?
- Shit.
- [Jack] You don't have yours?
- Nah, I lost my
keys like a week ago.
- I don't have keys
for the apartment.
- You don't have keys
for the apartment?
- No, you guys never did,
you never went down to the
shop thing and got 'em.
- Whatever, let's just go
and let's just see the movie,
and just worry about this later.
- Alright, he's right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We're wasting time here,
let's just go see the movie...
- Just worry about it later.
- Yeah. We'll just go.
- Alright.
- Yeah, let's just go.
- Cool. Who's driving?
- My keys are on the same
chain in the apartment.
- My car's in the shop.
- I don't have a car, so...
- Were you gonna try
to fix that problem
any time in your
adulthood, Jack?
- How do I fix not having a car?
- Getting a car.
- Alright, fine, okay,
let's just take a cab.
- Alright, let's call a cab.
We'll get there somehow,
let's call a cab.
- Cool. Let's get a cab.
- Let's get a cab.
- Problem solved.
Let's just get a cab.
- [Ryan] Do you have your phone?
- My phone's in the apartment.
- I threw my phone in
the ocean on a dare.
- Why?
- Because someone dared
me to do it, so I did it.
- Well, I...
- You don't have a phone?
- I don't have a phone.
- You still don't have
a phone? Jesus fucking.
How old are you?
Sorry, how old are you?
- 27.
- (laughs) Okay.
- What does my age have...
- What does your age have
to do with having a phone?
Your goddamn phone?
You're a grownup!
- Hey! Stop!
- How old are you?
- 27! I'm 27.
- Years?
- Yeah, years. What
else would it be?
- Alright. No movie.
Let's just go eat. Come on.
Let's just go eat.
- Alright, yeah,
let's just go eat.
- Okay, let's get food.
Let's go eat some food.
Do you have your wallet?
- I'm gonna say
this, and I feel like
you guys might know it already.
- You don't have a wallet.
- I don't have a wallet.
(laughs)
- Alright, alright!
- What, I thought you knew!
- You don't have a wallet?
You don't own a wallet?
- 'Cause you get sore
asses for a while!
You put the wallet
in your back pocket,
and you have scoliosis!
- What are you talking about?
Where do you put things?
- You have scoliosis
in your back!
- Where do you put
dollar bills and cards?
You put the wallet on
the bottom of one cheek
for years and years and years--
- Are you fucking crazy?
What are you talking about?
- Trying to fix their posture!
- What are you talking
about? Are you insane?
- I'm trying to fix my posture!
- You don't own a wallet?
- It kinda makes sense.
- I can add like three
inches to my height!
- Come on, let's just...
What do we have in our pockets?
I have...
- Empty your pockets.
What do we got?
- I brought a bag of chips.
- Chips.
- Fuck, I... Shit.
- You have to stop
bringing that.
- Yeah, that's my fault.
- I have this bag of weed.
- Let's just smoke some
pot and eat some chips.
- Smoke some pot and
eat some chips. Boom.
- That's our day.
- Not a big deal.
Let's just do it.
- That'll be fun.
- Jeez. (laughs)
Well what are we smoking out of?
- Oh yeah, pipe's inside, sorry.
- You serious? Are you joking?
- Hey. Let's just eat the chips.
- Please like and subscribe
to DeadKevinSketch,
and tell us a story about a time
you got locked
out of your house.
That sketch was intense,
but don't worry.
We're still friends,
right, guys?
Did it work?